Narendra Modi's recent visit to
Israel, the first ever by an Indian Prime
Minister, marks India's transformation
from reflexive hostility to a close
partnership with the Jewish state. While
security and trade have driven the
change, there's also another often overlooked
reason: Within India, the Left lost the
argument.
India opposed the 1948 creation of
Israel at the UN, and didn't establish
full diplomatic relations until 1992.
Both international and domestic
considerations shaped India's stance.
Diplomats worried about offending Arab
countries; politicians worried about
offending Muslim voters. Modi's visit
reflects a deeper shift in public
opinion. Many middle class Indians now
view Israel not as a neo-colonial
oppressor but as Americans do: as a
plucky country in a tough neighborhood.
Some are also attracted to the ancientness
of Jewish culture which, like
Hinduism, predates Islam and Christianity.
The Israeli Foreign Ministry found India
to be the most pro-Israel of the
countries it surveyed, ahead of even the
US. Close ties with Israel make sense
to middle class Indians. Today the notion
of slowing down or underplaying India-Israel
ties finds few takers outside
India's rapidly dwindling Left.
To learn more about my take on India-Israel ties,
check the links in the description below.
Also let us know what other topics you
want our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.